now if you're doing commercial
toothpaste
in the hopes that it will clean your
teeth
make your breath fresh
you might want to think twice in order
for this to make sense i first need to
explain
what your spit is made out of okay your
saliva you produce a tremendous amount
of saliva every day it's 1500
milliliters that's over 51
ounces of saliva
every single day
now what's in saliva well you have
electrolytes trillions of bacteria you
have an enzyme to help you break down
starches
you have a protein that helps coat
vitamin b12 so that it can pass through
the stomach and get absorbed into the
small intestine there's mucus in there
to keep everything flowing then you have
sodium bicarbonate that is baking soda
so the glands in your mouth actually
make baking soda to help neutralize the
acids that are occurring in the
fermentation process when you feed
your microbes in your mouth too much
sugar as well as the candida there's
this byproduct of a certain acid
and that ph is important because if the
acid is too acidic
you're going to develop cavities in your
saliva there's actually white blood
cells
there's all sorts of antibacterial or
specifically anti-pathogenic factors and
it's important
not to disturb the chemistry of what's
in that saliva because if it's too
altered to one way you start getting
inflammation in your gum as gingivitis
or periodontal disease
you start developing cavities you start
getting an overgrowth of yeast
or candida on your tongue
you start developing bad breath chronic
calitosis
and you can even develop biofilms which
are microbial
colonies in slime
and calcium in your tonsils
so i hope now you understand the
importance of the saliva and what it's
doing
to help clean your mouth and keep your
breath fresh and prevent all these other
diseases that can happen in your mouth
so think about this here you use
commercial toothpaste right what's in
commercial toothpaste well you have
fluoride which is very harmful to both
good and bad bacteria you also have
triclosan well actually they just banned
it that's a chemical that acts as an
endocrine disruptor which creates
resistance to certain bacteria and then
they put
sodium lauryl sulfate the same stuff in
your shampoo they put that in your
toothpaste like a lathering or a foaming
type cleaning detergent which what do
you think that does to your friendly
microbes then you have propylene glycol
the same stuff they put in antifreeze
they put that in your toothpaste which
is a solvent which can also contain
something called dioxin which is a
carcinogen in fact sodium lauryl sulfate
can also contain dioxin as well which
like i said is a carcinogen
and on top of everything let's put some
artificial flavoring in there some
artificial coloring
some parabens which are endocrine
disruptors chemicals that eventually
turn into formaldehyde and in the icing
and the cake let's put a little
carrageenan in there which creates
inflammation in your gut here you are
thinking you're doing your mouth some
good by using this commercial toothpaste
when in fact it's altering the
microbiome and the chemistry of your
saliva
so i want to give you a very simple four
ingredient recipe to make your own
toothpaste which is very inexpensive and
that has absolutely no side effects and
will give you nothing bad or negative
it'll actually support your healthy
saliva you start off with one teaspoon
of coconut oil okay then you add a half
of a teaspoon of baking soda then you
add a fourth of a teaspoon
of hydrogen peroxide food grade
three percent don't add 35
then you simply add three drops of one
of those oils okay it could be clove
cinnamon you could also use oregano oil
of course the scent might taste like a
pizza but
i think these other ones are really
really beneficial so this is a slight
modification of another recipe i gave in
this video on how to prevent
plaquing check it out i just put it up
right here